Générique
...
-Bonjour, bienvenue
dans "Politiques, à table !"
On se retrouve
comme chaque semaine,
autour d'un plat,
d'un dessert
et d'un invité.
Nous recevons
Stanislas Guerini.
-Bonjour.
-Merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation.
Avec moi,
Jean-Pierre Montanay.
-Bonjour à vous deux.
-Bonjour.
-Vous êtes ministre
de la Transformation
et de la Fonction publique,
nommé depuis mai 2022.
Vous avez été
un des tout premiers
de l'aventure En Marche.
Vous rejoignez l'entourage
d'Emmanuel Macron dès 2015
grâce à deux proches,
Ismaël Emelien
et Benjamin Griveaux.
Vous faites tous partie
de la bande de la Planche,
du nom de cette rue
du 7e arrondissement,
dont sont issus
les "DSK Boys".
C'est place des Ternes, dans le 17e,
que tout commence.
Votre appartement sert
de quartier général.
On connaît la suite.
Emmanuel Macron est élu.
Vous aussi.
Député de Paris,
patron du parti,
avant de devenir ministre.
Vous gardez
votre simplicité,
et vous n'oubliez pas
vos origines,
qu'on retrouve dans le menu.
-En effet, un risotto
tout simple
mais quel risotto,
un risotto à la milanaise.
En dessert,
une salade de poires.
-Le ministère de la Fonction
publique consomme responsable.
Nous sommes allés
vérifier en cuisine.
-Alors que
la sécheresse sévit,
pourquoi ne pas utiliser
les eaux usées
pour irriguer les cultures ?
La France compte
rattraper son retard
par rapport à d'autres.
-Allez, on passe à table.
Tout de suite,
Cuisine et confidences.
-Vous avez été habitué
à l'excellence.
Prénom de prince,
qui signifie "gloire",
rien que cela,
des fonds de culotte usés
sur les bancs de l'Ecole alsacienne
et du lycée Henri IV.
La crème de la crème.
Lorsqu'il s'agit
de partager un plat
pour rendre hommage
à vos racines italiennes,
pas question
de pâtes aux pois chiches, non,
vous optez naturellement
pour l'excellence,
le roi des risottos,
un risotto à la milanaise,
dont la création
remonterait au 16e siècle.
La légende dit que c'est l'assistant
d'un riche maître verrier,
qui avait l'habitude de teinter
ses verres avec du safran
pour les rendre brillants,
qui a eu l'idée
d'incorporer
ces précieux pistils
dans le riz,
lors d'un mariage,
pour lui donner
cette couleur
unique, nacrée et dorée,
comme on peut le voir
et comme on va le goûter.
Depuis 5 siècles,
la recette a évolué,
pour aboutir
à ce risotto divin,
souvent méconnu
chez nous en France
mais qui est une
des sept merveilles
de la cuisine italienne.
Est-ce que vous validez ça ?
-Complètement.
Vous m'apprenez beaucoup.
Vous me donnez envie de donner
le premier coup de fourchette.
Alors, on va le goûter !
-Tous ensemble.
-Il a une couleur incroyable.
-Il est parfaitement réussi.
C'est vrai, moi,
c'est un risotto
que j'ai toujours aimé,
celui que j'ai découvert
à la maison.
J'ai des origines
italiennes,
un grand-père
qui était italien.
-Nord ou sud ?
-Vers Bergame.
Donc l'Italie du nord.
C'est un grand-père
que j'ai jamais connu,
c'est le paradoxe.
Parce qu'on a
cette culture italienne.
Je me bats toujours
pour pas mettre d'accent
à Guerini,
c'est italien.
Il n'y a pas d'accent en italien.
-C'est votre papa
ou votre maman ?
-Mon papa.
Donc, mon grand-père,
qui est venu très jeune,
dans les basques
de son propre papa à lui.
Comme beaucoup
de "Ritals"
à l'époque.
Ils ont fui
l'Italie du fascisme
et sont arrivés
dans le Gers.
Deux cultures
qui se marient.
Le paradoxe chez moi,
c'est qu'on a jamais
parlé italien.
Mon grand-père est mort très jeune.
Il s'appelait Daniele.
Et il tenait
à ce qu'on parle français
à la maison.
Il est venu assez jeune,
adolescent, en France,
il a travaillé très tôt.
Mon papa et mon oncle, eux,
n'ont jamais parlé italien.
C'est plus tard
que l'Italie
est revenue.
-Ils étaient empreints
de cette culture italienne ?
-Jeunes,
pas tant que ça.
C'était le Gers,
Bagnères-de-Bigorre,
des racines sud-ouest.
C'est plus tard,
dans ma famille,
par le parcours professionnel
de mon père qui a un jour
travaillé en Italie,
qui a appris l'italien...
Et avec mon frère,
on a eu envie de retrouver
ses racines.
Et tout ce qui s'y est attaché.
A la maison,
on cuisinait ce risotto.
-Vous mangez italien !
-On mangeait italien, oui.
Il y a des traces.
C'est aussi intéressant
sur l'intégration,
l'assimilation...
Mon père tenait à ce que ce soit
vraiment la France,
et lui, il avait,
je pense, aussi,
une distance avec l'Italie,
l'Italie du fascisme.
Il avait fui.
Il avait envie
de cette assimilation française.
Il y a toujours des choses
qui restent.
Qui passent au-dessus
des générations.
-Donc, ça,
c'est le plat
familial
des Guerini ?
-Oui, j'ai appris
à cuisiner très tôt.
C'est un plat fantastique,
le risotto.
Qui prend du temps
de préparation.
C'est le secret
aussi...
-12 minutes, environ.
-Il faut le laisser reposer.
Les amateurs connaissent
le "mantecare".
-C'est quoi,
votre petit truc ?
-Le truc...
-Vous avez l'air
spécialiste !
C'est le dernier geste.
-Il faut pas
se précipiter.
Quand on a fini
de préparer le risotto,
on a mis le bouillon de légumes,
on a incorporé le safran,
quand c'est un risotto
à la milanaise,
et puis, à la fin,
le premier réflexe pourrait être
de mettre du beurre, du parmesan,
et de manger.
Erreur.
Il faut laisser
le risotto
reposer dans le plat,
c'est ça, le "mantecare".
Il va prendre
toutes les matières grasses
de la fin de la cuisson.
Le beurre et le parmesan
vont s'incorporer.
Ils vont donner le liant.
-Ca veut dire aussi,
c'est ce geste...
On pose le beurre,
qui doit être froid,
et le parmesan,
sur un risotto chaud,
qu'on couvre.
Ensuite, on fait ce geste,
pour remuer,
et ça va extraire,
faire sortir
l'amidon du riz
qui permet
ce liant
avec la matière grasse.
Le riz ne doit pas être
trop humide comme une soupe,
c'est ça,
la difficulté du risotto.
-Il est un peu craquant.
Légèrement al dente.
Comme pour les pâtes.
-Et donc, voilà,
on retrouve ça
dans l'assiette et là,
il est magnifiquement préparé.
-Il y a une recette familiale ?
Votre papa le préparait ?
-Oui, c'était familial
mais c'est intéressant,
on l'a enrichi...
Au fil des ans.
Je l'ai cuisiné plus tard.
Moi-même, en famille.
C'est un des plats
que je maîtrise.
J'en maîtrise pas
tant que ça
mais quand je cuisine,
c'est souvent ce risotto.
J'ai élargi un peu la gamme.
Je fais
des risottos au citron,
des choses comme ça.
-Ce n'est pas que à la milanaise !
-Ca s'est élargi, aussi.
Au citron, aussi,
qui est un super risotto.
-En hiver.
-Ca dépend des saisons.
-Aux champignons ?
Aux asperges ?
-Avec des petits pois.
C'est... C'est sans fin, en fait,
la famille des risottos.
-J'imagine que vous connaissez
mais j'ai trois astuces
pour réussir un risotto.
On va voir si M. Guerini fait
un risotto authentique.
On va aller vite.
Il faut surtout pas
de riz basmati.
Plutôt un carnaroli
ou un arborio,
qui sont des riz italiens,
pas faciles à trouver.
Mais dans les grandes surfaces...
Si vous en trouvez pas
dans votre coin du Cantal,
rabattez-vous sur
un riz long de Camargue.
Il faut faire un bouillon de poule.
Il y a le bouillon cube...
Mais vous mettez une poule,
avec céleri,
carottes, oignons.
-Plus long !
-Ca, c'est deux à trois heures.
-Je me suis jamais lancé dedans.
Enfin, il y a des sachets.
-Et à la fin...
Au début du premier geste,
le riz, on le met dans du beurre
et de l'huile d'olive.
Mais dans le risotto
à la milanaise,
on remplace le beurre
par une matière grasse,
de la moëlle de boeuf.
On fait blanchir...
-Oh là là.
Moi, j'ai jamais fait ça.
-On la met dans
la casserole,
dans ce mélange
d'huile d'olive
et du moëlle,
dont on va enrober le riz
pour le faire cuire
dans le bouillon.
Ca, c'est "l'autentico".
Comme on dit
en italien !
-Bellissimo.
Il parle en italien.
...
-Vous parlez
magnifiquement !
-Mi sto avvicinando a scuola.
J'ai appris à l'école.
-Capisco !
Il rit.
-Je le disais
tout à l'heure.
C'est pas
une transmission directe
mais c'est l'envie de retrouver
des cultures italiennes.
Mon frère et moi à l'école,
on a appris l'italien.
J'ai eu l'occasion
de le pratiquer un peu...
Quand on s'appelle Guerini,
on a envie de parler italien.
-Les origines...
D'avoir cette double culture.
Il y a le risotto,
mais la cuisine italienne nous offre
des tas de plats alléchants.
Il y a d'autres plats italiens
que vous cuisinez
chez vous ?
Les pâtes ?
-Evidemment.
Mais non, en fait,
en réalité...
Tout ça, c'est un grand bordel,
vous savez, la cuisine.
Tout ça,
ça se mélange.
Je dois avouer que j'ai une épouse
qui cuisine magnifiquement bien.
On mélange un petit peu.
Les pâtes,
c'est un incontournable chez nous.
-Avec quoi ?
Vous les mélangez
comment ?
Vous avez des recettes ?
-J'aime les pâtes
les plus simples possibles.
J'aime les pâtes
avec
de l'huile d'olive
et du poivre.
C'est les plus belles.
Il faut des pâtes de qualité.
Il faut les cuire
qualitativement
al dente.
Et ensuite...
-Un petit peu
de pecorino ?
De parmesan ?
-Un peu de parmesan râpé,
bien sûr.
Et là, c'est magnifique.
-La "cucina povera",
c'est du sud de l'Italie,
alors que vous êtes du nord,
vous aimez cette cuisine ?
On parlait des pâtes
aux pois chiches.
Vous aimez ça,
aussi ?
-C'est délicieux.
J'aime cette cuisine simple.
Ca a du sens aussi, pour moi.
Ca permet aussi...
De décarner les assiettes,
de végétaliser les assiettes.
C'est un plat
qui est végétarien,
qui peut se manger avec
des tranches de jambon,
c'est vrai
que c'est délicieux.
Faut pas le refuser.
C'est aussi un plat
qui a du sens
quand on essaye
d'aller vers des cuisines
plus végétales,
avec un peu moins de viande,
de viande rouge.
C'est le sens de l'histoire
et de ce qu'on doit retrouver
dans l'assiette.
-Est-ce que vous avez
d'autres plats signatures ?
Des plats plus classiques
de cuisine française ?
Ou vous ne savez pas trop
les cuisiner ?
-Je suis très classique.
Quand je vous parlais
des pâtes,
plat de base
dans notre alimentation,
c'est beaucoup ça.
Vraiment, je laisse
toute la sophistication
de cuisine à mon épouse
qui, elle,
cuisine extrêmement bien.
-Le Gers vous a pas influencé ?
-Elle cuisine
des plats
d'Ottolenghi.
-Il est connu partout.
-Extraordinaire.
-Simple.
-Ouais, exactement.
-Facile d'accès.
-Génial.
Il permet de faire
de la cuisine
avec beaucoup
de légumes,
avec des saveurs qu'on retrouve pas
dans la cuisine française.
Oser des choses...
Ca va être des poulets.
C'est souvent extrêmement
cuit avec beaucoup d'épices,
de saveurs...
Des plats de pâtes.
Je pense, par exemple,
à un plat de riz,
avec des tomates,
de la cannelle dedans.
-Cuisine orientale.
-Avec des épices,
effectivement.
-Quand je vous parlais
de "bordélisation"
dans les assiettes,
c'est mieux
qu'à l'Assemblée...
On la retrouve.
-Le Gers vous a pas influencé ?
-Ah si.
Quand même,
c'est une terre...
-Très riche.
-Foie gras.
Vous le cuisinez ?
Vous êtes un peu embêté ?
-J'ai une grand-mère
de Bagnères-de-Bigorre,
c'est du côté paternel.
Cette famille est arrivée
dans le Gers, à Eauze,
et a ensuite bougé vers
Bagnères-de-Bigorre.
Elle cuisinait
du foie gras cuit
avec...
-Poêlé, c'est ça ?
-Avec des grains de raisin.
Qu'elle préparait minutieusement.
Elle enlevait tous les pépins
dans les grains de raisin,
pour les couper en deux,
les cuire à la poêle,
avec de l'armagnac.
Du foie gras poêlé...
-Pas mal !
-Magnifique.
De l'autre côté familial,
du côté de ma maman,
c'était Sarlat.
Le Périgord noir.
Je ne peux pas
ne pas vous parler
des pommes de terre sarladaises
avec un magret de canard.
Un plat qui est riche,
pour le coup,
en matières grasses !
-Des bonnes graisses.
De la bonne graisse.
-Du bon cholestérol !
Rires
-Quand ça nous arrange.
Des plats
que vous cuisinez toujours ?
-C'est des plats
qui étaient
réservés aux vacances,
aux moments
chez mes grands-parents.
C'est un rapport au temps
qui est différent.
On est,
comme beaucoup de familles,
pressés par le boulot,
avec forcément
un peu moins de temps,
et les pommes de terre
sarladaises,
ça prend un peu de temps.
Il faut l'avoir.
C'est des plats,
que je réservais
à la cuisine familiale
de vacances.
Ce sont des souvenirs.
-On mange différemment.
Plus léger, avec moins de viande,
vous en parliez.
-C'est vrai.
-Votre alimentation a évolué
avec les années ?
-Ouais, bien sûr.
Euh...
C'est quelque chose qui,
maintenant,
arrive beaucoup plus
dans les habitudes
familiales.
C'est un sujet
extraordinairement
important.
Il y en a peu qui alignent
autant les intérêts
qu'on peut avoir.
L'intérêt
budgétaire, de santé,
et d'environnement.
On voit
qu'il y a beaucoup de sujets
qui créent des contradictions
dans notre société.
-Et dans les familles.
-Et dans les familles aussi.
On a la chance,
avec l'alimentation,
d'avoir un sujet
qui peut réconcilier
beaucoup d'injonctions
a priori contradictoires.
Pouvoir mieux manger,
avoir du plaisir
dans l'assiette,
intégrer les enjeux de santé
qui sont déterminants...
En disant ça,
je pense aux jeunes enfants,
aux conséquences
qu'il y a...
L'obésité,
aujourd'hui,
c'est un problème
qu'aucun pays n'a réussi
à résoudre.
Et donc,
par l'alimentation,
on peut aligner les intérêts.
C'est très difficile
de le faire.
Je discutais
avec un sociologue
qui me parlait de ça,
en me disant :
"Il y a des sujets
avec de grandes contradictions."
Le tabac,
c'est un sujet
de grandes contradictions
mais on a réussi
parce qu'on a changé
la culture.
Aujourd'hui, on a cet enjeu
dans l'alimentation.
Prendre ce sujet,
c'est, en cascade,
résoudre beaucoup de problèmes,
de santé, des problèmes budgétaires,
les conséquences
des dérives en matière
de santé, d'obésité,
sur notre système de santé,
elles sont énormes.
Mais aussi
pour des sujets
de la vie quotidienne.
Le rapport
de ce sociologue,
c'était de me dire
que les problèmes de harcèlement
à l'école,
c'est très souvent lié
à des sujets
d'obésité
chez les enfants.
-Ils se moquent des gros.
La grossophobie.
-Les enfants obèses,
en sortie scolaire,
vous voyez ces enfants
qui sont isolés
et entre eux.
Ca m'a sauté au visage
quand il a dit ça.
On voit que le rapport de ce qui
se passe dans nos assiettes
avec des enjeux
de société
comme celui du harcèlement,
qui est central
et qui doit être,
et qui est,
une mobilisation
nationale...
-L'alimentation a un rôle.
-On voit les conséquences.
Ca doit changer dans la vie
des Français, des familles,
ça doit aussi changer
dans la restauration collective.
Je me sens une responsabilité forte.
Vous prenez la restauration
dans l'Etat,
c'est 400 millions
de repas...
Chaque année !
-C'est un vrai levier.
-Voilà,
changer les choses.
On va apprendre des choses
au travail,
dans la restauration collective,
on emmène ça chez soi,
et peut-être
mieux manger...
Et réussir à réaligner
les intérêts.
La santé du portefeuille
et de l'environnement
sont alignées.
-Vous parlez beaucoup
de la santé.
Ce qu'on mange
est déterminant.
Vous faites attention
à ce que vous achetez ?
Vous regardez bien
les étiquettes ?
Ou est-ce que vous achetez
précisément du bio,
parce que les pesticides,
c'est dangereux ?
-Un peu comme tous les Français,
on est sans cesse
dans des contradictions.
On essaye de bien faire.
Voilà, je pense...
Le fait de se poser la question
de ce qu'on donne à ses enfants,
ça change complètement
la donne.
Il y a une attention plus forte
qu'on peut avoir sur les enfants.
Les contradictions de grignoter,
quand il faudrait pas grignoter.
Euh...
Se laisser aller
à des gourmandises,
des trucs
où il y a
des adjuvants, dedans...
Les trucs...
Personne peut dire
que c'est parfait.
-Y a pas des aliments
que vous avez bannis
de la maison ?
"Là, c'est vraiment mauvais."
-Moi, le truc assez net,
c'est manger moins
de viande rouge.
Voilà.
Euh...
Pour moi,
c'était plutôt
une considération
environnementale,
plutôt que la santé,
alors que c'est les deux.
Mais quand on voit...
J'ai l'occasion
de faire des ateliers
de travail là-dessus...
Avec mon cabinet,
on a fait un atelier
qui s'appelle
l'atelier 2 tonnes.
2 tonnes de CO2 :
notre objectif.
Aujourd'hui,
on est à 9-10 tonnes.
Vous voyez,
sur ces 9 tonnes,
il y en a 2,5 qui sont liées
à l'alimentation.
On a un enjeu
là-dessus.
On ne doit pas faire
des leçons de morale
surtout
quand il y a des difficultés
de fin de mois,
des difficultés
à boucler
le panier.
On doit donner
les bonnes informations.
On doit montrer
qu'on peut réconcilier ces sujets,
avec le plaisir dans l'assiette.
C'est très important
d'embarquer
par la pédagogie,
et en retrouvant
une notion de plaisir.
-On va en parler,
effectivement,
après,
aussi.
-En deux mots,
pour revenir à la santé,
vous parliez du temps.
Sur l'autel du temps,
vous êtes prêt à sacrifier
de la bonne alimentation
en achetant
des produits transformés
ou du surgelé ?
-Bah, vous voyez,
aujourd'hui,
ça fait partie
de mes arbitrages
les plus difficiles.
Je vais pas
vous faire croire...
-Vous avez peu de temps.
-...que, justement,
j'ai beaucoup de temps.
On va souvent vite.
Ce que je constate,
c'est que c'est pas beaucoup
plus long
de cuisiner bien...
-Exactement.
-Et à partir de matières
non transformées.
Je vais pas faire croire
que je passe
trois heures de plus
à cuisiner.
Je pense
qu'on peut bien faire
en faisant
des choses simples
qui permettent
de réconcilier tout ça.
-Vous évitez
ces produits transformés.
-Oui, j'en mange moins,
en tous cas, qu'il y a 10 ans.
Au début de ma vie professionnelle,
je ne mangeais à peu près
que des plats cuisinés,
ce qui avait...
-Raviolis en boîte.
-Ouais.
-Ca, c'est bon.
-Pas pour un Italien !
-Non, non, si, si,
j'en ai mangé beaucoup.
-Alors, on va déguster
ce vin
avec ce risotto à la milanaise.
C'est un médoc
que vous avez souhaité
partager avec nous.
C'est un grand vin
de Bordeaux.
A l'entrée
de l'estuaire de la Gironde.
Au-dessus
de Saint-Estèphe,
de Saint-Julien...
Très belles appellations.
C'est un AOC, évidemment.
Les cépages, cabernet sauvignon,
merlot, petit verdot et malbec.
C'est un millésime 2017.
Sa particularité :
des arômes de fruits
rouges, noirs,
et du café torréfié.
Vous reconnaissez le médoc
que vous aimez ?
-Alors, moi, je suis pas du tout
un oenologue
ou un grand spécialiste,
donc, là, je bois vos paroles
avant de le goûter.
Sans vouloir rendre jaloux
ceux qui nous regardent,
on peut dire qu'il est
extrêmement bon.
Je trouve que ça marche
très bien avec un risotto.
C'est un vin qui me parle.
C'est, là-aussi,
des racines familiales.
Le médoc...
C'est Castelnau,
pour moi.
C'est une part
des origines de famille,
côté maternel,
cette fois.
C'est un vin
qui est enraciné
dans une histoire
familiale,
ça égaye un repas.
Je retrouve
tout ce que vous avez dit.
Vous l'avez infiniment mieux
commenté que moi.
-Le vin, c'est une histoire
de famille chez les Guerini.
-Oui.
Mais tout simplement de ceux
qui aiment passer à table.
Et c'est vrai que ça va...
On est français !
Avec un beau repas.
C'est une histoire de famille.
Il s'avère que ça remonte
très, très loin.
Je crois même que
ma famille
a été liée
à un domaine viticole,
le château Lagune,
dans le Médoc.
Ca n'est plus du tout
le cas aujourd'hui.
Ce sont des attaches qui sont
profondément dans les terres.
-Une question pour Brigitte.
Quand on a un risotto comme ça
ou un plat avec des épices,
le safran,
c'est assez fort,
qu'est-ce qu'il faut prendre ?
Du rouge ou du blanc ?
Pour faire exister...
-Il y a un paradoxe.
L'accord des couleurs
marche à tous les coups.
On accorde la couleur du vin
et la couleur du plat.
Avec un poulet, par exemple,
il vaut mieux prendre du vin blanc.
Là, comme il y a du safran
et que c'est assez relevé,
je trouve que l'accord
se marie très bien
avec un vin rouge,
qui est assez puissant.
C'est un accord réussi.
Elle rit.
-Bon, bah, tant mieux.
J'ai toujours
été marqué
par un truc avec le vin,
c'est la façon dont
on en parle,
l'instant
qu'on prend autour.
-A partager, bien sûr.
-C'est...
Moi, je suis pas spécialiste.
On peut avoir un goût
qui varie
avec la psychologie qui va autour.
Quand on vous parle bien
d'un vin,
quand on vous décrit
l'accord
avec les aliments,
tout change, quoi.
C'est ça,
la magie des mots
qu'on peut mettre autour
des sensations culinaires,
et c'est extraordinaire
avec le vin.
On aime entendre
parler du vin.
Vous en parlez très bien
et donc,
ça rend le moment
agréable
et sympathique.
-On va vous si
vous êtes incollable
en cuisine.
Le quiz.
-Alors, du sang italien
coule dans vos veines,
ce qui fait de vous
un amateur de parmesan.
Le roi des fromages
de la Botte.
Dites-nous si ces affirmations
sont vraies...
-Vous allez être déçus.
Il lit la première affirmation.
...
Oui, c'est vrai !
Non, aucune idée.
Vu comme c'est formulé,
c'est sûr que c'est vrai.
-C'est vrai !
-J'ai regardé beaucoup
de jeux télévisés.
Il lit la deuxième affirmation.
...
-C'est la deuxième question ?
Euh... Mais non. Bien sûr !
Ce serait réducteur
que de penser ça.
-Il y a quatre
races bovines.
D'où, vous l'avez dit,
la richesse
de ce fromage.
-Vous n'avez pas compris
que je suis fort en jeux !
J'ai beaucoup regardé
la télévision
et donc...
-Deux sur deux.
-Il n'y aura pas
d'appel à un ami !
Il lit la troisième affirmation.
...
-Bien sûr.
Ils sont très connus.
C'est les fameux 140 mois.
Rires
-Il a raison.
Je mets juste un bémol.
C'est pas très connu.
C'est exceptionnel et rare.
Mais ça existe.
A mon avis,
ça doit être le max.
Ca commence à faire beaucoup.
-Les questions
n'ont pas été données avant.
Il lit la quatrième affirmation.
...
-Ca, euh...
Je pense que c'est faux.
-Oh !
-Oui !
Surtout pas le congeler !
-Bien sûr.
-Il est italien,
maintenant,
on en est sûrs.
-On va essayer
de le piéger.
Il y a un deuxième quiz.
Vous avez été
au lycée Henri IV,
un roi gourmet.
Sauriez-vous
nous dire si ces affirmations
à son sujet sont vraies ?
Elle lit la première affirmation.
...
-Ca doit être bien vrai.
-C'est vrai.
Elle lit la deuxième affirmation.
-Non, bien sûr que non.
Elle rit.
-Ah, c'est vrai !
Rires
Le truc, c'est de mettre
beaucoup d'assurance.
Vraiment...
Elle lit la troisième affirmation.
Oui, c'est un restaurant
qui existait déjà à l'époque.
-Non mais c'est vrai.
-Il adorait...
Il adorait le pâté de héron.
A la Tour d'argent...
-Je l'ai mal connu
mais sans doute.
Elle lit la quatrième affirmation.
...
-Ah ! Les dernières questions sont
toujours plus dures dans le quiz.
Je pense que c'est vrai aussi.
-Alors, non, c'est faux !
-Ah là là !
-Il adorait les huîtres.
-Quand même !
-Vous m'avez eu !
Vous m'avez eu.
Rires
-C'est souvent à table que se nouent
les meilleures histoires
ou des deals politiques.
La Brève de comptoir.
Stanislas Guerini,
vous avez réfléchi
à une anecdote
sur un repas.
Vous avez une histoire
à l'esprit ?
-Quand vous m'avez posé
cette question,
le truc qui m'est tout de suite
venu à l'esprit,
c'est les repas militants.
Tout bon
responsable politique
sait que,
pour avoir du monde à une réunion,
il faut inviter
à manger
et qu'il y ait un coup à boire.
Ca fait les plus belles réunions.
Tous les maires savent ça.
Quand ils font un grand repas,
une fois par an...
-Là, ça fonctionne.
On est sûrs d'avoir
les voix derrières ?
-C'est beaucoup plus compliqué !
Je ne m'aventure pas là-dedans.
On est sûrs qu'il y aura du monde
et qu'on va passer
un bon moment.
Au fond, c'est ça qui m'a...
Quand vous m'avez demandé,
j'ai pensé à tous
ces moments militants.
J'ai été chef de parti
pendant trois ans et demi.
J'ai été à la tête d'En marche.
C'est pas toujours facile.
Quand on se prend...
Pas tout le temps
des victoires électorales,
et plein d'emmerdes
quand on est à la tête d'un parti.
Il y a aussi plein de moments
qui sont magnifiques.
Il y a quelques jours,
on était réunis pour le campus.
A Bordeaux.
Moi, j'ai organisé
les premiers campus.
C'était à Bordeaux,
il y a plus de quatre ans.
C'était toujours
des moments
absolument
incroyables,
qui réunissaient,
autour de moments militants,
le soirs,
autour de banquets,
de nourriture.
C'est des moments,
en fait,
où il se passe des trucs
dans votre vie
que vous auriez jamais
imaginés.
Il y a 4 ans,
on avait invité le chef Raoni.
Il défend la forêt
amazonienne.
Et il est venu.
Avec une délégation,
comme ça.
Et puis on était là,
assis autour d'un plat.
On partageait un moment.
C'était extraordinaire de pouvoir
parler avec le chef Raoni.
-La photo est à l'écran.
-Ah bah voilà.
C'est un moment
qui est, pour moi,
extrêmement...
Extrêmement émouvant en réalité...
Il parle des causes,
de ses combats,
et c'est un moment
qui est hyper humain,
c'est un moment de partage.
C'est vrai aussi que le moment
partagé autour d'un banquet,
ça permet ça.
Pour la petite histoire...
-Vous avez mangé avec lui ?
-Après, on a mangé un bout.
Et ce qui est quand même
étonnant et marrant,
c'est qu'on parle
des sujets importants,
en soi, la forêt amazonienne,
le poumon de l'humanité.
Il y avait un traducteur.
-Il parle un dialecte
amazonien ?
-Ouais, ouais.
Je comprenais rien
et j'attendais
à chaque fois.
Il se passe des trucs
dans les yeux.
Vous avez des traductions
en attendant de saisir.
Et au bout d'un moment,
j'ai compris que le chef Raoni
avait des besoins naturels,
et ça faisait une demi-heure
qu'on était ensemble.
Le traducteur me dit
que le chef doit nous quitter
car il a envie
d'aller aux toilettes.
On s'est marré.
Le chef Raoni
a pu aller aux toilettes.
Ce sont des moments
de vraie vie...
-Et de partage.
Rires
-On va cuisiner et consommer
de façon plus vertueuse.
On va beaucoup s'y mettre.
Comment s'y prend-on ?
Que trouve-t-on dans l'assiette ?
C'est Le dessous des plats.
Dans votre ministère,
vous montrez l'exemple
avec des pratiques
plus respectueuses
de l'environnement.
Pas que dans l'assiette !
Une consommation
responsable,
qui s'impose
plus largement
dans la fonction
publique.
Nous nous sommes invités
dans vos cuisines...
-Allez, bon courage.
-9h, arrivée
des dernières livraisons.
-On a reçu des escalopes.
On va faire
des escalopes milanaises.
Cette semaine...
Allez-y.
-Cette semaine,
mais pas aujourd'hui.
Ce midi,
ni viande ni poisson
au menu du ministre,
et des 80 collaborateurs.
De la secrétaire
au conseiller le plus proche.
-Aujourd'hui,
nous avons une raviole
de légumes
avec une tendance
un peu asiatique.
Avec un bouillon miso
qui accompagnera tout ça.
Vous avez du shiitake,
de la carotte,
du céleri...
On garde les produits de saison.
-En plat,
un parmentier
de légumes.
-Là, je fais une tuile
de pommes de terre.
Un petit peu
d'huile de noisettes.
C'est la saison.
Voilà.
-Depuis deux ans,
deux fois par semaine,
les menus du ministère
sont végétariens.
Une cuisine
plus vertueuse,
plus respectueuse
de l'environnement,
mais pas seulement.
-Honnêtement,
il y a aussi les coûts
des matières premières,
qui a accéléré
le fait qu'on consomme
un peu plus
de légumes.
Tout a pris des prix
de plus 10, 12 %,
au niveau de la viande
et je parle pas
du poisson.
Les légumes restent encore
des produits abordables.
-Derrière les fourneaux,
l'équipe a dû
s'adapter,
redoubler
d'inventivité.
-Le but,
c'est quand même
qu'ils aient
assez à manger.
Des fois,
avec les légumes,
on peut avoir tendance
à donner
un petit peu moins.
Avec les légumes,
les légumineuses,
les féculents,
on arrive tout à fait
à proposer
des repas complets,
diversifiés.
-On a la chance
d'avoir un retour
du ministre
et des conseillers,
qui sont contents
d'avoir goûté...
On a des conseillers
qui disent :
"Moi, j'aime pas ça,
mais j'ai goûté.
"Du coup,
j'ai trouvé ça bon."
-Lassana ?
On va aller emmener
le compost.
Tu viens ?
-Les habitudes
de travail
ont changé.
Plus question de jeter
les épluchures.
-Y en a pas mal,
aujourd'hui.
Pas mal de... Le chou-fleur
a été fait, les panais...
-Elles sont désormais
valorisées.
Ca se passe
dans le compost.
Au fond des jardins
du ministère.
-C'est avec les jardiniers
de Matignon,
on valorise le produit
de A à Z.
Ce compost va servir à fertiliser
le petit coin de légumes qu'on a.
Et d'herbes aromatiques.
-Je mets des feuilles
pour pas que ce soit sec.
Quand j'ai fini,
on va mettre en place.
-Tiens, regarde.
On va en prendre
un petit peu.
-Le ministère de la Fonction
publique est un précurseur
mais d'ici quelques mois,
les 2500 cuisiniers de l'Etat
seront formés aux enjeux
d'une alimentation
plus sobre.
-Stanislas Guerini,
pourquoi avoir imposé
deux menus végétariens
par semaine
dans votre ministère ?
-Bah, d'abord, vous voyez
que ça suscite pas de difficulté.
Parfois,
c'est un casse-tête
mais j'ai beaucoup
de fierté,
en regardant le reportage,
qu'on vient de voir,
en voyant notre chef,
Marc,
qu'on voit à l'image.
Un chef exceptionnel.
Et... Pourquoi on a fait ça ?
Parce que, tout simplement,
les moments qu'on vit,
ce quinquennat doit être celui
du changement d'échelle,
de la planification écologique.
Ca doit se faire dans
tous les champs
de politiques publiques.
-Aujourd'hui,
la loi,
c'est un menu végétarien
dans les cantines.
-C'est même pas...
-Vous allez plus loin ?
-En l'occurrence,
quand on est
la fonction publique,
on a à la fois
une responsabilité
pour nous-mêmes...
L'impact, je vous le disais,
il y a 400 millions de repas
qui sont servis
dans l'Etat.
-400 millions.
-C'est considérable.
On peut décliner ça
sous toutes les dimensions.
Sur l'énergie, sur l'eau, etc.
C'est un impact
extraordinairement fort,
mais on a aussi
une force d'entraînement
pour le reste de la société.
Les gens nous disent
qu'on est sympas
de leur demander
de faire ça ou ça
et des efforts
de sobriété.
"Que faites-vous, vous ?"
-Il faut montrer
l'exemple, c'est ça ?
-Bien sûr.
J'ai vu qu'à chaque fois qu'on a
commencé par nous-mêmes, l'Etat,
on a été crédibles pour
demander des choses.
Ca s'est passé comme ça
pour la sobriété énergétique,
c'était il y a un an,
on a lancé ce grand plan.
On a dit qu'il fallait arriver
à réduire de 10 % nos efforts.
Et l'Etat,
on s'est engagés très fortement.
On l'a fait en six mois.
Je pense que ça rend crédible
pour demander des choses.
-Toute la fonction
publique se met
à ce rythme ?
-C'était dans votre reportage,
dans le cadre de la planification
écologique, on forme 2500 chefs.
C'est très, très important,
en réalité,
de pouvoir accompagner.
Ce à quoi je crois
pas du tout,
ou de moins
en moins,
d'autant plus
en étant
ministre
maintenant,
c'est l'effet circulaire...
On écrit dans une circulaire
ministérielle...
-Tout est vertical.
Du management.
-Faut que ça se voit.
Faut que ce soit
du concret.
-Faut pas que ça se fasse
sur le dos des administrations
et ni des agents.
Souvent,
je remarquais que c'était perçu
comme ça.
On donnait des règles qui faisaient
très bien sur le papier
et ensuite, on disait :
"Espérons que dans trois ans,
"les trucs soient faits."
-"Faites ce que je dis,
pas ce que je fais."
-Comment accompagner
et crédibiliser ?
Le rôle d'un gouvernement,
c'est pas de faire
des leçons de morale.
C'est de fixer
de la norme, évidemment,
et aussi de mettre les citoyens
en capacité de pouvoir faire.
C'est vrai aussi
dans les administrations.
Ca veut dire...
-Ca entraîne les citoyens ?
-J'en suis convaincu.
La règle seule,
elle ne suffit pas.
On voit bien qu'il y a plein
d'injonctions contradictoires.
En parler ne suffit pas.
Il faut se donner les moyens
de réussir.
Ce que j'essaye
de faire, à ma modeste échelle,
qui est celle de l'Etat,
celle de la fonction
publique,
c'est d'accompagner
et donner les outils.
Cet exemple
de la formation
des cuisiniers,
parfois,
j'ai noté que ça faisait
sourire certains.
On va mettre de l'argent
pour pouvoir former...
-Les former comment ?
Retirer la viande ?
-Ca va être des formations
qui sont approfondies.
Aux achats.
Il y a des enjeux
sur les achats,
à la décarbonation
des assiettes.
-Les jeunes chefs ont
cette conscience qui ont changé.
-Il y a un petit côté
générationnel.
J'ai l'impression
que tout le monde a envie,
et là...
Les jeunes comme les anciens, etc.
Quand on s'y met,
c'est un effet d'entraînement,
en réalité...
C'est pas si simple que ça.
Ca veut dire qu'il faut
aller chercher des diversités
de produits, de légumes,
de penser les saisons...
Il y a des légumes
plus résistants,
qui vont nous permettre
cette société d'adaptation
face au changement climatique.
-Consommer différemment.
-C'est très fin.
Ca se décrète pas
comme ça.
Si, du jour au lendemain,
vous imposez à tout le monde
de retirer
tel ou tel aliment,
vous allez être
dans la contrainte.
Si vous apportez
des solutions,
en montrant
comment faire...
Ca se voyait à l'image.
On peut faire
des plats magnifiques
et qui correspondent
à nos besoins.
Là, ça change tout, quoi.
-Vous dites de regarder ça
mais les cuisiniers aiment cuisiner
des légumes,
ça les embête pas.
Mais j'attends
la réaction des agents !
Y a pas eu des résistances ?
-Un peu.
-Des viandards sont
montés au créneau ?
-Bien sûr.
Je vous raconterai.
"Est-ce qu'on va avoir assez ?
Moi, j'ai besoin de mes calories."
-Les protéines !
-Les protéines, bon.
Et rapidement, voilà,
c'est un débat
qui n'existe plus.
-Tout le monde s'est mis
au diapason ?
-Je vous le garantis.
Je fais pas
semblant
comme au quiz.
C'est pas de la langue de bois.
Aujourd'hui, la réalité,
c'est que plus personne
dans l'équipe,
la petite PME
qu'on constitue,
remet en cause ce qu'il y a
dans les assiettes.
C'est ce que je disais.
La nourriture est un
des rares sujets
où on aligne les intérêts.
Il y en a peu,
comme ça.
C'est intéressant,
le chef le disait,
les prix ont augmenté.
L'inflation
alimentaire...
-Ca réduit le coût
de l'alimentation,
dans le budget de la ménagère.
-Je pense que...
On a un très beau sujet.
Avec une force...
-A condition de ne pas consommer
de produits bio qui peuvent
être plus chers que des locaux.
-Justement, ça va permettre
de faire basculer le fait
de mettre du budget,
par exemple,
dans de la viande,
en se disant
qu'on va acheter des produits
qui coûtent plus cher.
Il faut rémunérer
ceux qui le font.
Et aussi...
-Bon pour la santé.
-Et aussi ouvrir un marché.
C'est ça, l'intérêt.
Pas que l'exemplarité.
Quand on prend la restauration
collective,
privée ou publique,
bah, ça permet
de faire basculer,
ou d'ouvrir un marché,
pour démocratiser,
justement,
la nourriture bio.
-Vous ouvrez le marché
du bio,
mais que dites-vous
aux éleveurs ?
Eux, ils ont effectivement
leurs bêtes,
ils ont un manque à gagner
qui est important.
-Ca va permettre
de pouvoir privilégier
la récompense de la qualité,
de pouvoir,
là où on va économiser,
car on va décarboner
l'assiette,
on va pouvoir consacrer
un peu plus de budget à acheter
de la viande de bonne qualité
et récompenser les filières.
La filière d'élevage française
est une filière d'excellence
qui doit être rémunérée
pour le travail
qu'elle mène.
Et pour son excellence.
Ca va permettre d'acheter
plus circuit court, français,
d'acheter plus bio,
éventuellement,
et c'est comme ça
qu'on va réconcilier
les injonctions contradictoires,
et on doit, nous,
au gouvernement,
défaire les noeuds.
Et trouver des solutions.
-Question provoc'.
En Suède, les ministres
mangent à la cantine.
Quand on voit les cuisines
du ministère,
ça ressemble
à un grand restaurant.
C'est dans l'ère du temps ?
C'est le modèle
français ?
Au moment où on doit faire
des économies,
on peut
continuer à entretenir...
-En l'occurrence,
on le fait.
Il y a des contraintes
budgétaires assez fortes.
Là, les chefs
et la brigade
travaillent
pour 80 personnes qui travaillent
pour deux ministres
dans les bâtiments
dans lesquels on est.
Une petite équipe.
C'est pas démesuré.
C'est aussi, c'est vrai,
une chance immense,
de pouvoir accéder,
tous les jours,
à une nourriture de grande qualité
avec cette attention portée.
C'est pour moi,
vraiment, l'occasion
de valoriser le travail
d'agents publics qui sont
extraordinairement
engagés,
qui font des choses
qui ont du sens
et donnent du sens
à leur boulot.
"A travers ce que vous faites
pour nos assiettes,
"peut-être
qu'on va irriguer,
"accompagner,
former,
"sensibiliser aussi des gens
qui ont des leviers
"de décision
très importants."
Peut-être un des projets
les plus importants
que j'ai lancés
depuis que je suis ministre,
c'est la formation de 25 000 cadres
de l'administration
à la transition écologique.
On y parle alimentation,
on y parle CO2,
on y parle biodiversité,
à travers les espaces verts,
on y parle crise des ressources.
Ce projet-là,
qui n'est pas
une formation, une visio,
et puis c'est fini, hein,
c'est 3 jours de formation
pour tous ceux
qui ont les leviers de décision
les plus importants.
Les préfets,
les directeurs
d'administration,
nos ambassadeurs...
Toute la haute fonction publique
est formée
et les retours
qu'on a de ce projet
sont extraordinaires.
Je le dis comme je le pense.
Non seulement on est en train
de changer les choses
sur les enjeux
environnementaux,
mais on est en train de changer
les choses sur la façon de manager,
de penser l'action publique.
Et ça,
c'est une opportunité
extraordinaire.
On a beaucoup de choses
à remettre à plat
dans la façon
de conduire
les politiques.
De l'assiette
aux politiques publiques,
on peut changer
les choses.
-Vous parliez d'environnement.
2023 devrait être l'année
la plus chaude jamais connue
sur cette Terre.
Un réchauffement
et un dérèglement qui nous plongent
dans une pénurie d'eau,
indispensable à la vie sur Terre.
Les pieds dans le plat.
-Oui, les épisodes
de sécheresse sont
de plus en plus
fréquents.
Les expérimentations
sur les eaux usées
dans l'agriculture se multiplient.
La France est en retard
sur d'autres pays.
Un exemple sur l'île
de Porquerolles,
dans le Var,
un reportage
de France 3 PACA.
-100 000 mètres cubes d'eau
nécessaires chaque année
pour les habitants de Porquerolles.
Dans cette station d'épuration,
une fois traitées,
les eaux usées sont déversées.
Les rayons UV du soleil
font le reste.
-Cette eau,
au lieu d'être
rejetée telle qu'elle
dans le milieu naturel,
c'est-à-dire,
à la mer,
elle est rejetée
dans les lagunes...
Ce qui permet, dans un traitement
biologique, sans aucun apport
de produits chimiques,
de faire le dernier traitement
qui permet la réutilisation
dans l'irrigation agricole.
-17 hectares de végétation
sont irrigués
mais ces eaux
n'étant pas propres
à la consommation,
l'aspersion est interdite.
Unique option :
le goutte à goutte.
-Cette eau permet
l'irrigation de parcelles
soit de fruits issus
de l'arboriculture
qui touchent pas le sol,
ou des fruits qui seront
transformés,
des confitures, des soupes.
C'est un exemple à suivre.
Ca fait 40 ans
que ces installations sont là.
-L'île économiserait
jusqu'à 10 %
de sa consommation.
Pour ce militant
de la protection
de l'environnement,
encourager cette pratique
présente un risque sanitaire.
Il préconise plutôt
de changer nos habitudes.
-Vous avez le risque qu'il reste
des bactéries, des virus,
des parasites,
des produits chimiques.
Réduisons
notre consommation
et ensuite, peut-être,
voyons comment réutiliser
l'eau usée traitée.
-France Nature Environnement
craint aussi
que ces eaux réutilisées favorisent
une agriculture intensive
dans une aire
où l'eau
est devenue
un bien très précieux.
-Alors, ce sont 1 %,
M. Guerini, des eaux
usées qui sont réutilisées
à des fins agricoles
en France,
contre 90 %
en Israël,
14 % en Espagne,
60 % à Malte,
8 % en Italie...
Comment expliquer
un tel retard ?
-Je suis pas un spécialiste
de l'agriculture, moi.
On a des normes
et parfois
une complexité
administrative
qui empêche
la réutilisation
des eaux.
On voit à quel point
c'est un enjeu, aujourd'hui.
C'est très intéressant,
avec France Nature Environnement,
qui nous accompagne
dans nos projets,
montrait qu'on doit,
à mon sens, pas opposer
la sobriété des usages,
on doit diminuer
notre consommation en eau,
on pourra y revenir,
si l'Etat s'y met, là aussi,
ça aura de l'impact,
et mieux réutiliser
les eaux.
Je constate
qu'il y a des acteurs,
dans l'agriculture,
des acteurs industriels,
complètement empêchés
de pouvoir réutiliser
leur propre eau,
dans leurs process.
-Les ARS sont pointilleuses.
-Par des normes.
Les ARS appliquent la loi,
les normes
qu'on se donnait.
Elles ont fait
qu'on a pris un retard
en matière
de réutilisation.
-On consommait l'eau
car on en avait beaucoup...
-Donc, il faut pas opposer les deux.
-En fait, on faisait pas attention !
-On a besoin
de faire les deux.
On a besoin d'être plus sobres
dans nos usages,
et de plus réutiliser.
Je vous donne
un exemple.
Depuis deux ans,
on a mis en place un dispositif,
appelé France Expérimentation.
Ca permet d'accompagner
des acteurs,
des PME, des boîtes,
qui ont des projets
innovants
et qui se trouvent empêchés
par la complexité
administrative,
le droit.
On a accompagné en l'occurrence
Volvic, Danone,
les usines,
pour vérifier avec eux
et les suivre
dans la réutilisation
de leur eau usée.
C'est pareil
que le reportage.
Ils nettoient
trois fois l'eau.
-En circuit interne ?
-Cette eau-là,
ils pouvaient pas
la réutiliser
pour nettoyer
leurs cuves industrielles.
-Pourquoi ?
Des résidus de bactéries ?
-On est allés voir
de nos yeux.
Ils me disaient que c'était absurde.
L'eau, vous l'auriez bue.
-Elle était
consommable ?
-L'eau propre
et potable,
c'est différent.
-Oui mais elle était
trois fois filtrée
et elle était remise à un niveau...
De l'eau issue de leur process
alimentaire, industriel.
La réglementation
les empêchait
de réutiliser
cette eau-là,
pour nettoyer
leurs cuves
industrielles.
C'est absurde.
A se taper la tête
contre les murs.
-Attention
aux risques sanitaires.
-Ce que je veux dire,
c'est qu'en accompagnant...
On a eu un suivi
encore plus particulier,
des retours,
de ce que ça pouvait donner.
On l'a suivi avec les autorités.
On y est allés
à plusieurs ministres.
Environnement, Fonction publique,
pour simplifier et Santé.
On a vu qu'il n'y avait
aucune difficulté
en matière de santé,
et les deux projets
dont je vous parle,
c'est 600 millions
de mètres cubes
tous les ans
qu'on va pouvoir
sauver
car on les réutilise,
alors qu'ils étaient...
-A quelle fin ?
Dans l'agriculture ?
-En l'occurrence,
dans un process industriel.
-Pour nettoyer des machines.
-Des cuves.
-Toute la chaîne sert.
-Ca, c'est une petite révolution.
-Vous avez
l'objectif de baisser
de 10 % la consommation.
-C'est la partie sobriété.
Si on réduit dans
la fonction publique,
juste pour l'Etat,
de 10 %,
c'est comme si toute
la ville d'Angoulême
s'arrêtait de consommer
pendant un an.
L'impact qu'on peut avoir.
-A quelle échéance on peut
réduire de 10 % ?
-D'ici un an.
-D'ici un an ?
Ca veut dire
qu'on gaspille de l'eau ?
-Ouais.
Bah, enfin,
je veux dire...
-10 %, c'est quand même beaucoup.
-Les fuites...
-La réalité,
c'est que c'est
faisable.
C'est faisable,
c'est extraordinaire
avec ce sujet,
sans impacter
notre qualité de vie au quotidien.
C'est faisable avec des trucs
où parfois, on se dit :
"Pourquoi on n'a pas fait ça
avant ?"
En mettant des mousseurs
sur les robinets.
Vous vous lavez pas moins bien
la main avec un mousseur.
En mettant
des dispositifs
dans les chasses d'eau.
Pardon d'aborder ces sujets
qui sont un peu terre à terre.
Une chasse d'eau,
c'est neuf litres d'eau
potable.
Vous imaginez
qu'on verse de l'eau potable
pour l'usage de la chasse d'eau.
On a des dispositifs
qu'on va mettre, bêtement,
dans les chasses d'eau,
qui permettent de gagner
1,5 litre à chaque fois.
Ne me faites pas croire
que ça a un impact
sur la qualité de vie
au quotidien
des fonctionnaires.
On peut y arriver.
Il faut qu'on ait
des démonstrateurs,
pour montrer
que les choses sont faisables.
On a fait 10 % d'économie
sur l'électricité
et le gaz.
-On est capables
de le faire sur l'eau ?
-On va
le faire sur l'eau.
C'est une extraordinaire
force d'entraînement
de dire qu'on peut réussir.
Je vous le dis :
plus on le fait,
plus on va le faire.
Il y a cet effet,
aussi, d'entraînement,
où on se dit
que c'est possible.
Ca donne du sens
au travail.
Je crois que ça fait longtemps
qu'on n'a pas eu une opportunité
aussi extraordinaire
que la transition écologique
pour donner du sens
au travail des agents publics.
J'ai mis des sujets sur la table.
Je parle parfois
de rémunérations
au mérite.
Ca peut tendre.
Si on se disait que
dans les objectifs qu'on se fixe,
qui pourraient être
pour un plan d'intéressement
pour les fonctionnaires,
on mettrait
les questions de réussite
de nos plans de sobriété,
sur l'énergie, sur l'eau.
Ca aurait du sens.
C'est parfaitement
mesurable.
-Vous voulez le faire, ça ?
-Ouais. Ca fait partie
des projets
que je porte.
C'est pas un sujet tabou.
La fonction publique
doit relever aujourd'hui
des grands défis.
La transition écologique,
la transition démographique,
la transition numérique,
et ces défis
doivent nous conduire
à repenser la façon
dont on travaille,
dont on objective les choses,
dont on mobilise les agents
et ça donne beaucoup de sens.
Mettre des enjeux de rémunération
en face de ça,
c'est pas tabou.
-Tout le monde a fini.
On passe au dessert.
Le péché mignon.
-C'est le temps
du sucré.
Avec des fruits
de saison.
C'est ce que vous avez choisi,
pas n'importe quel fruit !
Chez Françoise a préparé
cette salade de poires,
très bien organisée.
Pas d'incident en vue.
On m'a dit que vous ne supportiez
pas tous les fruits.
-Ah oui, c'est vrai.
C'est bête comme chou,
j'ai des allergies,
comme plein de gens.
-Avec quel fruit ?
-Avec les fruits à peau.
-La poire en a !
-Oui, pardon,
c'est vrai.
J'ai l'air bête.
Mais des fruits de type
avec les petits poils dessus.
-Les kiwis ?
-Les abricots ?
-Les pêches,
les brugnons...
-Allergique ?
-Donc ça réduit un peu...
-Le champ des fruits !
-Les poires,
pas de problème.
-Un bon fruit de saison.
-C'est un bon fruit.
Vous êtes pas très dessert ?
-Non.
Je suis beaucoup moins sucré
que salé.
Il fallait bien choisir un dessert
sinon vous n'alliez pas
m'inviter, donc...
-On vous aurait invité quand même.
-Je me suis dit :
"Prenons des fruits de saison."
Ca a du sens
et c'est cohérent...
-Par rapport
à votre discours.
-...à ce que je fais
dans les actes
et les assiettes.
C'est sympa
de manger des fruits
de saison.
Ca oblige à se creuser les méninges.
-Desserts italiens ?
Tiramisu, tout ça ?
-Si mais j'ai pas voulu
faire trop "rital".
Non !
On aurait pu la faire 100 %
italienne.
-Il faut assumer !
-Tiramisu.
C'était vraiment de nous emmener
vers le haut.
-Sinon,
les légumes
de saison,
5 fruits et légumes
par jour, à peu près.
Vous y êtes ?
-Grâce à Marc que vous avez vu
en vidéo, je pense que j'y suis,
mais c'était pas le cas
il y a quelques années.
Voilà.
-Vous arrivez
à en faire manger
à vos enfants ?
Ca peut être compliqué
dans les familles.
-Je suis comme tous les parents.
C'est la grande galère.
C'est la bataille
quotidienne.
Ca aide, encore une fois,
d'avoir des talents culinaires
à la maison...
Ca permet...
-Y a des astuces.
-Exactement.
-Mettre un petit fruit...
-On est comme tout le monde, quoi.
-On finit toujours cette émission
en musique.
Vous avez choisi celle-là.
On l'écoute.
"La quête", Orelsan
-Maman est prof de maternelle
C'est même la maîtresse d'à côté
J'ai 5 ans
Et je passe par la fenêtre
Pour aller me planquer
Dans sa classe
Elle me dit :
"T'es pas censé être là"
Je lui dis :
"Près de toi, c'est ma place"
J'aime que les livres
J'préfère être seul
Je suis content
Quand il pleut
-Vous avez choisi
cette chanson d'Orelsan.
-C'est pas Paolo Conte ?
-J'aurais pu, j'aurais pu.
Je me suis marié
sur Paolo Conte.
-Pas très bon
au blind-test !
Rires
Pourquoi ce choix ?
-Vous me parliez
de mes enfants
il y a quelques secondes,
c'est ce qu'on écoute
en voiture, ensemble.
On est très Orelsan,
récemment.
On écoute tout Orelsan.
Voilà.
Notamment "La quête"
qui est une super chanson.
L'important,
c'est pas que le chemin,
c'est la quête.
Pas la quête,
le chemin, pardon !
N'importe quoi.
C'est le verre de vin.
Rires
Bah, d'abord,
parce que, voilà,
c'est la transmission
et ce qu'on écoute en famille.
La transmission
dans l'autre sens.
C'est un artiste qui, moi,
m'a beaucoup touché.
J'ai regardé
le documentaire
où son petit frère
l'a filmé
depuis le début,
ce qui est juste inouï.
Et j'ai été assez touché,
en fait, par son parcours...
La normalité de sa vie
au début, à Caen,
le fait qu'il n'y avait pas
de rappeur à Caen,
tout simplement.
Et le fait qu'il construise
sa carrière,
qu'il aille vers la scène
avec ces moments extraordinaires
qui me font frissonner.
-Vous l'avez vu sur scène ?
-Non, jamais. J'aimerais.
Et euh...
Et de ce rapport
d'un artiste au public,
qui démarre au début,
qui se plante,
qui fait des contests
de rap,
etc.
Ca marche pas du tout.
Et puis,
petit à petit...
-Il devient un très grand chanteur.
-Devant des salles incroyables.
Au fond,
on voit très bien
le fait d'être entraîné
dans un truc
qui est plus grand que soi.
Je trouve que quand
on fait de la politique,
et moi,
l'engagement que j'ai eu,
c'est un peu pour ça aussi,
c'est d'avoir le sentiment
de participer à un truc
un peu plus grand que nous.
C'est vrai
qu'on se retrouve,
je parlais de moments militants,
de moments profondément collectifs,
à vivre un tout petit peu ça.
Quand on est avec quelques
milliers de personnes...
Moi, j'ai accompagné
Emmanuel Macron
au tout début,
quand il était à Bercy,
devant 20 000 personnes...
-La même chose qu'on vit sur scène.
-Il y a des trucs qui correspondent.
Donc, voilà.
-Merci, Stanislas Guerini.
-Merci à vous !
Pour la cuisine !
-Merci pour ces choix.
Un très bon risotto
à la milanaise.
Merci à Chez Françoise.
Merci pour la salade de poires.
Merci de nous avoir suivis.
Rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA